oh my god
on this thursday night
[Applause]
flash flooding paralyzes some of
america's biggest cities this is
unprecedented i think this is the worst
i've ever seen the record rain the
rescues and the role of climate change
our jackson prosco is in philadelphia
tonight
rising frustration with alberta's
premiere could jason kenny's plummeting
popularity hurt the federal
conservatives
spreading vital information as kovid
spreads we have zero leadership right
now the alberta doctors and scientists
giving kovid briefings because the
province is not and the transition to
clean energy what the future holds for
oil and gas workers
global national with donna friesen
we are in alberta's capital edmonton
tonight when the pandemic hit this
province was in a tougher position
economically than the country as a whole
hit by covet and a massive oil price
crash and what happens in alberta
doesn't stay in alberta good evening and
thanks for joining us alberta has the
world's third largest oil reserves and
is still one of the key drivers of
canada's economy and despite efforts to
transition to clean energy no one has
figured out how to quickly replace the
enormous wealth oil and gas generates
for albertans and for canadians we're
gonna look more deeply at the notion of
a just transition in a little bit but
first to the united states and another
sign just how unprepared our cities are
for extreme weather supercharged by
climate change entire communities are
underwater
in new york city flash flooding shut
that city down subway stations gushed
with water roads turned to raging
oh my rivers it's poor person's flowing
oh my god this is terrible
in just one hour eight centimeters of
rain fell in new york central park the
most ever recorded there in a single
hour scenes like that played out across
new york new jersey and pennsylvania
there are reports more than 40 people
have been killed some trapped in
basement apartments as the water surged
in
jackson prosco is in philadelphia
tonight jackson the rain has stopped the
sun is out now but the water is still
everywhere
it really is donna it has just started
to recede here in downtown philadelphia
but at one point these cars would have
been entirely submerged and stories like
this are unfolding up and down the
northeastern united states as they begin
to tally the toll of lives lost and
property damaged
the scope of the flooding is
unprecedented so is the scale of the
rescue mission i think this is the worst
i've ever seen i've been through a few
floods as an elected official in this
community
i have never seen it this
intense in this widespread
by helicopter by boat and even by
bulldozer rescuers pulled thousands of
stranded people from their homes and
cars but water came up so fast and so
unexpectedly that few had time to
prepare i know we lost everything you
know but materialistic everything you
know that you can
you know you can just repair you know
but family you can't bring back you know
what i mean so what i'm very thankful
for is for my parents my family that out
the house the remnants of powerful
hurricane ida spawned tornadoes in
maryland and new jersey
but it was the rain up to 250
millimeters in just a few hours that
brought catastrophe
an entire month's worth of precipitation
and then some
flooding new york subway
submerging cars and swapping houses and
apartments
among the dead are people who drown in
their own homes including a two-year-old
boy you know an extraordinary
sadly tragic
historic
24 hours in new jersey there's no other
way to put it with some of the largest
cities in the u.s deluged simultaneously
just days after ida ripped a path of
destruction across the gulf coast
officials openly acknowledged the role
of a changing climate the future we
spoke about in dire terms that future is
now it's happening we're losing life
lives we're losing property
beyond the incalculable loss of life and
the monumental cleanup is the fear about
what lies ahead
ida serving as both a disaster and a
warning about the future
we want to give you a sense of the
cleanup job facing cities big and small
in this region take a look at these
images this is a freeway that cuts right
through philadelphia it looks like a
canal right now it is in fact a freeway
obviously not supposed to be filled with
water like that that tells you just how
much water is out there and just how
much has to be cleaned up in the days to
come
donna
so much work ahead jackson frosco in
philadelphia thank you
we turn back to alberta now and the
fraught political climate here in the
midst of a serious fourth wave of cobit
19.
there is frustration in alberta much of
it directed at premier jason kenney who
now holds the title of least popular
premier in canada doctors and nurses are
incensed that in the midst of a fourth
wave most public health restrictions
have been lifted everyone has the right
alberta has by far the most active cases
of covid19 in canada more than 12 000
and more than 480 people are in the
hospital right now 114 of them in
intensive care that's almost double the
number a week ago the vast majority are
unvaccinated
all acute care beds are taken is the
message from the mayor of edson alberta
40 percent of them have coveted patients
under the age of 55. those looking for
leadership are getting none as school
starts parents and administrators are on
their own neither alberta's chief
medical health officer nor premier jason
kenney have held a briefing for three
weeks so a group of doctors and
scientists are filling the void we are
seeing a big physical and emotional
capacity issue with healthcare workers
holding their own covid19 briefings
i spoke to er physician dr joe vaipont
we have zero leadership right now we
haven't seen any of our politicians we
haven't seen our chief medical officer
of health
you know we're getting
really getting no help as as citizens
and so there's a real desperation out
there
for people to get
knowledge so that they can
make good decisions on risk and and
mitigating risk and so we're hoping to
provide that what are you hearing from
icu doctors and nurses
health care workers but other health
care workers and coveted wards are being
abused by the patients because a lot of
these people are are
you know anti-massacres anti-vasculars
that are quite angry with the fact that
they have covert they're quite angry
that they have to be in hospital and
there's there's actually significant
amounts of um
of health care worker abuse going on
right now which is it's tragic
when we're just trying to do our jobs
it's a really really hard time to be
working in health care in alberta the
premier has been absent for weeks there
have been no public health briefings
from the officer a medical officer of
health
what do you think is going on there do
you think that's a strategy
well i can tell you that we have zero
mitigation measures in place zero we
have no masking we have no uh physical
distinct requirements we have no
limitations on gatherings
and i'm not sure if this is intentional
but the consequence of this is that
covet is going to run rampant through
our unvaccinated population
on top of all that the province wants to
cut nurses salaries by 3 percent and
many albertans including conservatives
are fed up i mean
there's just a lot of things recently
especially when it came to jason kennedy
and the stuff that he's been doing
especially when it came to the nurses
and stuff that
i don't really believe in my wife's in
the healthcare
industry so yeah they're not not very
popular right now the cuts to the nurses
yes yes yes
still for 40 bucks you can buy this hat
best summer ever a fundraiser for
kenny's united conservative party
a time limited offer
lots of people have been wondering where
is premier kenny well he reappeared sort
of yesterday after being absent for
three weeks he did a facebook live
session choosing which questions to
answer and he said he's back at work in
his office with me from the alberta
legislature is global edmonton's tom
vernon tom all of this is happening
during a federal election campaign could
this disappointment with jason kenny
affect support for the federal
conservatives well donna you hear on the
radio commercials linking premier jason
kenney with conservative leader aaron
o'toole the opposition obviously think
that they can make hay with that i spoke
with one conservative candidate who says
outdoor knocking he hears disappointment
anger towards premier jason kenyon it is
impacting support he has to turn that
conversation back to well how do you
feel about justin trudeau and let's take
care of that in ottawa interestingly
enough during his facebook live last
night with albertans premier kenny said
he did not want to insert himself into
the federal election campaign this
coming from someone widely regarded as
one of the best campaigning
conservatives in the country
and tom in the last federal election the
liberals lost the two seats they held
here in edmonton what's your sense of
the political climate now and the chance
of winning those back
well they hope that the anger against
premier jason kenny will lead to gains
here in edmonton the two seats that they
lost last time around they believe they
have a very strong chance in winning
those ones back edmonton center is one
of them they have a long history of
victories in that seat and mcclellan won
it a number of times in very close
elections now it's not just the liberals
who think they can make gains here but
the ndp do as well they hold the only
non-conservative seat in this province
in edmonton strathcona they think they
can win another one jugbeat singh
actually campaigned here in the first
week of the campaign something he did
not do last time around
all right and back to premier kenny
what's your intel on his strategy why
lay low as covet cases climb instead of
showing leadership and being front and
center yeah the premier's in a very
difficult position here at the end of
june when he was announcing his
reopening plan he all but declared the
pandemic over in alberta due to
vaccination rates climbing he said when
he opens the economy it's not just open
for summer it is open for good now the
cases are rising and he's facing a tough
decision to make he had a covid cabinet
committee meeting yesterday they're
meeting again today sources say that
that was very divided on which way to go
he also has a strong element in his
caucus that is very opposed to any form
of covet 19 restrictions and has been
for much of the pandemic so he has to
manage his leadership he has to manage
the rising cases and he has to do so in
light of what he said in june and also
he was on vacation for two weeks at a
time nurses were being told they would
have to cancel their vacation to deal
with these rising cases
donna
all right tom vernon at the alberta
legislature thanks
a global transition away from fossil
fuels is underway and as it happens jobs
in the oil and gas industry will
continue to disappear the idea of a just
transition that a healthy economy and a
clean environment can and should coexist
sounds great but it is easier said than
done tonight heather urex west explores
what a just transition means and who is
caught up in it
[Applause]
in 1992 it was cod the collapse of the
atlantic canada cod fisheries killed
tens of thousands of jobs entire
families lost their livelihoods almost
overnight 30 years later hundreds of
thousands of oil and gas workers wonder
if they'll be next there's no doubt
anymore that we are transitioning away
from fossil fuels and that that
transition is moving faster than we
expected and just kind of burying our
heads in the sand isn't helping workers
employment in the industry has gone from
more than 228 000 physicians in 2014 to
about 188 000 now over 40 000 jobs have
disappeared in just seven years and
while more job loss may be inevitable
there is belief the pain can be
minimized if there is a plan our
research shows that you could phase out
direct fossil fuel employment in canada
over a 20-year period do it gradually
and almost all of the adjustment can be
taken up through early retirements and
other voluntary transitions it's being
called a just transition ensuring
workers aren't left high and dry as
canada and the world moves away from
fossil fuels we have to make a living
and where we come from in northern
alberta it's oil and gas janine campbell
cove is from the soto first nation near
grand prairie she's worked on pipelines
in northern alberta for close to two
decades i know a lot of people were like
you know what do you do what are we
going to do what can we do
and like the answer was always the same
it's you can't do anything for
indigenous workers like campbell cove
transitioning out of oil and gas can
mean having to move away from their
first nations communities last year an
injury left her no other choice i have
been working in the industry for about
12 13 years
pretty much straight out of high school
stephen buehler wants out of oil and gas
it's why he volunteers with iron and
earth a collective of oil and gas
workers calling on government to help
people like him find new career paths
maybe geothermal projects or helping
support wind and solar the solar
industry as well not everyone is eager
to leave iggy domikowski is the ceo of
tundra process solutions while he
believes his company will continue to
serve the oil and gas industry for the
rest of his career he sees things are
changing too
we'll always continue to focus on oil
and gas but a lot of the capital
projects like building these large oil
sands facilities those aren't really
happening anymore so naturally over time
our business has diversified and will
continue to diversify
because across this sector no one can
afford to be left behind
heather urex west global news calgary
canada's employers are struggling coming
up good help has been hard to find the
pandemics impact on the job market
we are at the university of alberta
which is on treaty 6 territory and
within the metis homelands of the metis
nation of alberta region 4. edmonton is
on the traditional territory of the cree
blackfoot denny stoney solto and
blackfoot people
we're back in a moment
you may have noticed help wanted signs
in lots of storefronts and restaurants
despite high unemployment some
industries are having trouble hiring
enough workers and gaviola explains the
employment paradox
across the country popular holiday
destinations have looked a little
different this year the pandemic has
forced closures and modifications at
restaurants and stores and a labor
shortage the likes of which employers
have never seen before
quebec's montreal was grappling with
labor shortages before covid but the
pandemic has made it much worse
immigration is at a relative standstill
and many workers are choosing government
support or moving on from the service
industry they may have child care issues
and safety concerns and with students
returning to school in the fall hiring
is expected to become even more of a
challenge so trouble will recruit
internationally they go to france they
go to middle east they go to
latin america and we have great stores
to tell people who are happy to embrace
these jobs
even in alberta which has suffered job
losses in the oil patch the pool of
candidates has shrunk during the
pandemic the business council of alberta
says employers are having trouble
filling positions across the board from
energy to agriculture with labor
shortages most acute in hospitality what
that falls back to is immigration and
both in terms of temporary foreign
workers
and you know immigration numbers overall
have been reduced the conference board
of canada's top economist says wages for
new hires have risen seven percent
compared to pre-covet levels in some
fields like health care and tech it's a
job seekers market a new kpmg survey
shows nearly 70 percent of employers are
struggling to find qualified tech
workers the innovation economy is now 12
of our gdp and is growing three to six
times faster than any other segment of
our gdp so we definitely need
new skills uh to participate in this
area
a high national unemployment rate along
with a growing skills gap and new labor
shortages are all symptoms of how work
has changed during the pandemic the next
federal government needs to keep a close
eye on all these factors or risk
jeopardizing the post-pandemic recovery
ann gaviola global news toronto
still ahead canada and coal we still
mine lots of it and export it when will
that end
canada is reducing its dependence on
coal for electricity though some
provinces like here in alberta still use
it and there is pressure for the federal
government to stop the export of coal
too because as eric sorenson reports
wherever coal is burned it contributes
to greenhouse gases and to climate
change
it's a panorama they don't feature in
the scenic tourism videos mountains of
coal awaiting export on british
columbia's west coast if you thought
canada was just about done with coal
it's more complicated than that
ontario shut down with some drama its
coal-fired power stations a few years
ago and while alberta plans to get out
in the next couple of years plants in
nova scotia and new brunswick say they
may have to burn thermal coal beyond
ottawa's 2030 deadline it is our
responsibility as utility to make sure
we do that in a prudent fashion this
week the liberal campaign went further
promising to stop exporting thermal coal
by 2030. with so many affordable and
cleaner options available the use of
coal for producing electricity simply
must come to an end but exports are not
coming to an end yet the vista coal mine
in alberta produces thermal coal and is
seeking permission to expand its
operations to export more
much of canada's coal like this massive
operation in southeastern bc is steel
making coal for export most canadian
coal mines are in bc and alberta in an
average year more than 30 million tons
mostly coal to make steel is shipped
through the west coast ports to asia but
along with it carbon intensive thermal
coal that critics say canada should not
be exporting the atmosphere doesn't care
where we burn this coal so there's no
question that uh the uh the export of
coal um is not consistent with with our
climate targets here in canada so it's
something we definitely need to move
away from canada isn't just exporting
our coal to asia we're exporting
american coal mining companies in
montana and wyoming also produce thermal
coal for asian markets but they have run
into environmental roadblocks in states
like washington and oregon so they are
detouring their coal into this country
and then on to asia they're trying to
send that call somewhere else to burn
and canada has provided up a port for
them to do that we take responsibility
for being green leaders in phasing out
coal when when the exact opposite is the
case
it will be hard enough to phase out
thermal coal use and exports by 2030 and
until then millions of tons of coal will
ship from and through this country to be
burned overseas eric sorensen global
news toronto
next the resilience of new yorkers
facing hard truths about climate change
if we needed another example of how
unprepared our cities are for the
extreme weather climate change is
creating we just got it people in
businesses on the american east coast
were getting back on their feet after
covid now hit by record flash flooding
and digging deep to find hope
yesterday morning the report was three
to six inches over the course of a whole
day which was not a particularly
problematic amount
that turned into the biggest single hour
of rainfall in new york city history
with almost no warning it's horrendous
honestly we lost so much stuff majority
of this is going to go in the garbage
this is really damaging i don't know how
my my dad will be able to do it
so now we've got to change the ground
rules from now on what i think we do is
tell new yorkers to expect the very very
worst it may sound alarmist at times but
unfortunately it's being proven by
nature
we're all going to come together and
we're going to figure out a solution and
we'll go from there
[Music]
that is global national for this
thursday night i'm donna friesen we
leave you tonight with one last view of
alberta's capital i'll be back at the
anchor desk tomorrow and next week i am
on the road again and next thursday will
be in badeck nova scotia
thanks for watching take care of
yourselves bye-bye
[Music]